allem auch emotionen ein gefühl steuert
mich wenn ich genau dieses kleid haben
muss obwohl ich schon wächst ganz
ähnlicher im schrank hängen habe oder
wie geht es ihnen trotz ihrer kleider
die sich hauptsächlich frauen genau er
selbst an gewicht gefühl dass wach
gekitzelt werden und wir haben diese
frau getroffen die dazu beitragen dass
dieses gefühl generiert die großen ideen
die gedeihen auch an den trostlosen
arten dieser welt irene müller weiß dass
gerade kreiert die trendforscherin für
einen schweizer grossverteiler eine neue
produkte wird ihr arbeitsmaterial
alltagsbeobachtungen laufsteg
impressionen und schlagen sie
interessiert sich für das aktuelle war
so und einfach muss dann muss er kriegt
man automatisch wie ein partien fügte
gefühl inspirations splitter an
sogenannten lud bord zu einem gesamtbild
[Musik]
das hier ist materiale letzten saison
denn die mut bord sind die heiligen kühe
der mode branche um streng geheim
die konkurrenz darf auf keinen fall
wissen mit welchen strategien hier
gearbeitet wird vermutlich sehr stark
emotional und das muss ja wofür mittler
oder nur mal quasi aus produkte die
genauen bauteile dieser geschichte sind
schwierig wirst du sicherlich die
detailseite kleidungsstücken spielen
eine zentrale rolle
sie sind die von zeitgeist von opulenz
oder reduktion erzählen von spruch drauf
oder oder oder oder
eigentlich liegt und durch immer mehr
weg die regelung hat früher selbst
erfolgreich mode entworfen die ein mal
hintereinander gewinnt für den zwist die
seine worden später verwandelt sie als
stylistin für einen us sport multi
profane laufbekleidung in beginnt werden
sie verknüpft labels mit einem
lebensgefühl
jede geschichte ist auch ein geschäft
[Musik]
das ganze inspiration versuchen impulse
wir dass man das an der mond scheint der
kommerz weit weg in den galerieräumen
das löwenbräu areal läuft das fitting
die anprobe einen tag vor der show die
gene müller ist engagiert um die
helvetischen die feier zu beraten
die inszenierung zu optimieren
klar
die mode läuft an talent und emotionen
es geht um kreativität und und kapital
aber die mode ist auch ein
verheißungsvolles versprechen jeder kann
alles weil sich fühlen wie er mit wir
sind hierbei als den ganzen tag
unterwegs um die vorbereitungen der
fashion show zu beobachten und zu sehen
wie die fieberkurve der aufregung
langsam aber sie verschweigt